[Music]
oh
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you
one of the most incredible cosmic beings
in marvel's history
um from the minds of jack kirby
this character has captivated me from
jack kirby to jim starling to ron lim
i give you sideshows maquette
silver surfer a magnificent piece
brought to you from the mind
and the creativity of the great daniel
bell
um this statue as soon as it went up for
pre-order
i was automatically in shout out to my
cousin
lord cognito from iron lords podcast
uh he purchased it as well
we unboxed them live uh both at the same
time
on dcx open mic uh
channel that i do fridays at 9 00 pm
shameless plug uh
and we we we did the unboxing but let me
let me get into this statue let me get
let me get into
the reason why i love this character and
the stories that that has been told
about this character
such a complex character such a ton
of amazing stories for me to choose from
i i chose it was two stories really
honestly that i was battling between the
two
i was battling between the two of the
surfer versus dr doom
uh when he first came to earth and
surfer versus maestro
uh in battle world uh
when dr doom became god doom and
melded the worlds together
[Applause]
i decided to go with the battle world
one
even though the funniest story
is him meeting doom for the first time
and and he finding out that
humans are absolutely corruptable but
when he
got a chance to go to battle world see
doom
created battle world and that was an
amalgamation of
all the universes combined into one when
they
split the multiverse and com collapsed
them in on one
and in dystopia uh
maestro hulk ruled and in his throne
room he had a broken
uh surfboard from the silver surfer but
the surfer was no longer
alive at that in that world that it came
from
being that doom made this world well the
surfer came back
into this world and he wanted his board
and he went to uh
maestro's castle and
he went to his throne room and maestro's
men ran
over there to tell maestro yo there's
somebody in the room
getting the trying to get to your throne
room he goes there he confronts the
surfer
you know he fights the surfer and
the surfer you know like swats on the
way the surf is so powerful
and you know he swats maestro away and
he goes
and he gets his board and he heals his
board and
you know and he he leaves and he and he
tells the hulk before he leaves uh make
sure
that i never have to return to see you
again you know for your sake
you know and it is it's just an
incredible
story one of the best stories of
surfer one of the ones i chose to use
today it's so many and hopefully we get
more silver surface statues to go
through this
but daniel bell went with
a simplistic yet intricate
and powerful stamps for this statue
it's three pieces it's the base it's uh
the board and uh
it's nova and nova has a lighter feature
function now nova is frankie ray
she used to be the girlfriend of the
human torch and she had
flame powers galactus came to the planet
and uh she gave herself up to be
galactus as
and from that moment on she was known as
nova
and she was galactus harold at the time
you know the surfer found her with
galactus
and he started to mentor her on how to
be a good herald
that's just the brief synopsis because
it's a
a piece of proximity piece that's not
really representative of the whole
statue but it has
key images from the whole statue so it's
a very nice proximity piece probably the
best proximity piece
that i received from a sideshow
but this surfer the anatomy on it it's
incredible
and the fact that you can see all the
colors
that's coming out of the space work
wormhole that he's coming out of that
he's emerging from
with his board now normally in some
artists
they have an angular board this board is
more of a shape in the front and i like
it like that that's ron lim style
that's a new style of the surfer opposed
to the older style the jack kirby style
where the board was like squared off
but you can tell the stance and the
power
of the surfer i love the fact that his
eyes
has the white in it and he
is shaded so perfectly it's not metallic
it's not chromed out but it gives you
that
metallic-like sheen to it it gives you
that chrome-like sheen to it
and it's a fantastic statue
it's one of the most amazing statues
that daniel bell has ever done
and he's done a lot that i'm a huge fan
of but i love this surf and i've
waited for a silver surface statue to
come out and i'm so happy that he got
the call to do it
because i love his work well this is the
part in the video
where i'm going to ask you to like
follow and subscribe
and hit that joy button hit that joy
button you know where that join button
is that join button is right there down
at the bottom
hit that join button so you can follow
me and all the lords at
uh iron lord podcast and find out what's
going on at the realm
and also go to lords of gaming.net where
you can find
old episodes of kos and old episodes of
the last word with lord cognito and
ibontis
right now outriders is doing incredible
things
destiny 2 has just released the new raid
and people are talking so much about
that stuff
please take your time out go see that
stuff
but also stick around look at this
statue
in all its glory and tell me
how dope that music is in the comments
at the bottom
see you next week when i give you a
statue
that might take over the world
[Music]
peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
you